[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant que clerc val de france ses
partenaires de l'epa paris-saclay pacte
pme parce que d'abord c'est la première
banque des entrepreneurs c'est aussi la
première banque à avoir son siège sur
paris saclay la banque populaire val de
france et au travers du groupe bpce est
partenaire premium des jeux 2024 donc
cela représente bien sûr de nombreuses
opportunités et la banque populaire
souhaite accompagner tous ses
partenaires fournisseurs clients et
contribuer bien évidemment à l'essor
économique de territoires paris-saclay
la banque populaire val de france est
une banque régionale donc l'économie
locale ça fait partie de notre adn
donc nous avons déjà 55 % nos
fournisseurs qui sont des fournisseurs
locaux
nous ce qu'on désire s'est développée du
partenariat avec les pme qu'elle nous
apporte l'innovation nous avons un
véritable défi à relever dans les années
à venir
nous devons faire évoluer nos usages nos
besoins seuls nous n'y parviendrons pas
nous avons besoin d'être accompagnés
nous avons besoin d'avoir une vision
extérieure d'experts qui puisse nous
interpeller et nous faire réfléchir sur
notre organisation et nos façons de
travailler
[Musique]
bonjour fils yves hasselin boutures
points comme on réalise donc des jardins
de biodiversité de bien-être avec de la
bienveillance en faisant travailler des
personnes qui sont en insertion
donc on a comme clients par exemple le
groupe thales le groupe suez le groupe
angie dans le cadre rencontre grands
comptes pme
on a rencontré donc le groupe suez et on
a pu présenter nos projets de
biodiversité de bien-être et de
bienveillance donc au groupe suez et on
a pu le réaliser l'aménagement de
lagence de mur sur yvette
cette manifestation c'est un véritable
levier pour nous pour accentuer
continuer à aller dans ce sens-là aller
encore plus avant et y avoir encore plus
de fournisseurs qui sont des
fournisseurs locaux et développer un
véritable partenariat avec eux
[Musique]